you know what that floor is sticky
you know why because i was able to touch
the backboard no i was like yo i need to
put it i need to play
honestly
i was like
i can't touch the backboard
come on just got it
we just need you go dunk one baby
remember back in the day in the gun
contest they had the time limit
[Applause]
with my guy birdman did it about six
three times
he loses he's losing the judges fellas
yes all he got to do is put it in and
isaiah's putting that thing around his
neck
oh my goodness we got to change it up
taking a big bite try to take a big bite
you're going to do it he's still gonna
do it
[Music]
remember when nate took a while
[Music]
he also won three times what do you
think do your thing
do the same dunk
without without
because the scores are not outrageous he
can get eight to nine eight
there you go there you go oh just a
regular but it works and green's got one
in the books better give them some some
eights and i get them seven
[Music]
this is this is shaq's pet peeve when
guys take this long but look at his head
though oh god i mean
he could have just came out and did that
right away just yep that would have been
great cool warm-up 45 yes
see he should have read
the landscape of the room all i need is
a 45 yeah just done that dump right
there
but
the problem is he thought that first
dunk was easy for him
and it wasn't oh because you're in eight
to seven yes
he's still in the building got one more
dunk club remember he had the first two
dunks
top two make it to the finals
top two
toad got cold cole's got to bring out a
50.
so cole anthony got it started with a
40.